-Guys, finally, we have
exactly eight shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time
for the beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It is time for "12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters."
Here we go.
-♪ 12 days
of Christmas sweaters ♪
♪ Eight days left ♪
-That's right.
Every show
between now and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
a heavenly Christmas sweater
from the "countdown
to Christmas" cabinet.
Since there are
eight shows left,
let's open door number eight,
shall we?
Hello.
This is it right here.
I'm very excited about this one.
-It's a good one.
-Last one was hard to top.
The last one, we had someone's
head coming through a chimney.
-Exactly.
-Yeah. Here we go.
Let's see what we have tonight,
yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Heavy.
It's got some weight to it.
Yeah.
Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Epaulets?
Now let's see who's going home
with tonight's sweater.
This is a heavy one.
Everyone look at
your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get a drum roll,
please?
[ Drum roll ]
284!
♪♪
Hey. I'm Jimmy.
Nice to see you.
Can you stand over there?
Welcome to the show.
What is your name?
-Catalina.
-Catalina, where are you from?
-Portugal.
-Hey!
Come on!
I'm so happy you're here.
-I'm happy, too.
-This is your color, basically.
-Yeah. It's my favorite color.
-It just happened that pink
is your favorite color?
Do you have anything like this
in Portugal?
-No.
I'm so happy.
-Yes.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Well, you haven't
tried it on yet.
-I'm sure it's going to be fine.
-Can you -- Can you try it on?
-Yeah, of course.
-Yeah?
Here you go.
It's got a lot of --
[ Cheers and applause ]
No, okay, I can hear you.
Catalina, oh.
[ Laughs ]
Wow.
Get your -- Oh --
You have -- Oh.
Get your hair out.
You look gorgeous.
That's what I'm talking --
Look at that.
That's how you rock the sweater.
Beautiful!
One more round of applause
for our winner.
Congratulations.
Thank you for being here.
Stick around.
We'll be right back with
Michelle Pfeiffer, everybody.
Come on back, now.